sean igual al 0 0 y b igual a 22 puntos
en el plano coordenada sea a veces
efe un hexágono equilátero esto es
importante equilátero eso quiere decir
que todos los lados tienen la misma
longitud convexo y convexo lo que quiere
decir es que no queremos cosas por este
estilo no queremos cosas con capas
digamos por ejemplo 1 2 3 4 5 6 esto
sería un hexágono cóncavo entonces no
queremos esto bien entonces queremos que
este este vértice esté votado hacia
afuera por así decirlo muy bien entonces
sea abc df un hexágono equilátero
convexo tal que el ángulo
efe ave es igual a 120 grados y luego
nos dan una serie de relaciones de
paralelismo entre los lados y además es
tal que las coordenadas de sus vértices
son miembros distintos del conjunto cero
2 4 6 8 10 el área del hexágono puede
ser escrita como m por la raíz de n
dónde m y n son enteros positivos y n no
es divisible por algún cuadrado de un
número primo esto quiere decir lo único
que quiere decir esto más bien es que
esta raíz está simplificada lo más
posible encuentra el valor de msn y bien
aquí ya me tomé la libertad de poner un
eje y las alturas a las que tienen que
estar los vértices los miembros de este
conjunto de hecho nosotros ya sabemos
algo por ejemplo el vértice ajá sabemos
que está aquí en el 0 0 el vértice a es
el 0 0 no puse las coordenadas x para no
confundirnos y tratar de irnos con la
cinta de las longitudes el vértice b
tiene que estar en coordenadas de 2 así
que está en algún punto de esta recta
digamos vamos a ponerlo aquí
si les parece bien aquí tendremos ave
que está en las coordenadas de dos
entonces éste sería un lado de mi
hexágono
estoy aquí
sería el lado de mi hexágono y por lo
tanto tiene una longitud s recuerden
todos los lados tienen la misma longitud
no necesariamente son iguales los
ángulos porque no es un hexágono regular
sino un hexágono equilátero pero ahora
bien el otro vértice que se conecta con
ad es el vértice efe y donde podríamos
poner al vértice f pues lo podríamos
poner en cualquiera de estas alturas
porque yo usamos el cero y usamos el dos
pero resulta que si lo ponemos por
ejemplo aquí en el 6
no podríamos dibujar un hexágono convexo
así que vamos a poner a nuestro vértice
efe vamos a decir que está por aquí ese
va a ser nuestro vértice efe de nuevo
esto sería un lado de nuestro hexágono
y aunque no lo parezca esto también
tendría longitud s
ahora bien el vértice ce ya no puede
estar ni en el 0 ni en el 2004
tiene que tener altura digamos 6 así que
vamos a poner a c por aquí
aquí tendremos al vértice ce de nuevo
este lado
en este lado tiene longitud s
bien y ahora donde podríamos poner el
vértice al vértice pues antes que nada
observen que si recorrí en esta diagonal
una longitud ese y subí cuatro espacios
entonces sí pongo al vértice aquí tendré
que regresar al eje y por qué
me pongo aquí el vértice la razón es
porque
este lado perdón también tiene longitud
s así que puedo pensar en esto aquí
podría haber un triángulo rectángulo
de hipotenusa s y lado 4 aquí tengo otro
triángulo rectángulo de hipotenusa s y
del lado 4 entonces este lado de aquí
tiene que tener la misma longitud
bueno y con exactamente el mismo
argumento podría probarles que el
vértice de tendría que estar aquí
y dónde es allí pues allí lo que resulta
es que el vértice el vértice de que
recuerden esto también es ese por el
mismo razonamiento que acá este vértice
de tiene que tener coordenadas b 10
porque recorrido distancia es esa acá y
ahora recorro distancia s en el sentido
opuesto así que algo así se ve mi
hexágono
esto también tiene longitudes y las
relaciones de paralelismo que me dan que
me dicen ave es paralelo a de ave este
lado es paralelo a d
luego veces es paralelo
efe bs
a veces es paralelo efe
pues más o menos parece que si
finalmente cede cd donde esta sede acá
esta sede 123 es paralelo a ese a eso
también podría ser creíble bien entonces
ya que tengo este hexágono lo que voy a
querer hacer es quizás primero encontrar
cuánto vale ese bien así que quiero
encontrar ese para después encontrar el
área déjenme voy a borrar esto de aquí
para que no nos estorbe en el futuro
bien entonces la longitud de s depende
de la inclinación que tenga esta recta
así que si yo llamo este ángulo este
ángulo lo voy a llamar theta entonces
ese va a ser función de teta y de hecho
recuerden que el ángulo
efe ave es de 120 grados así que cuánto
vale este ángulo de acá
vale este pues vale 180 menos 120 menos
teta 180 menos 120 es 60 así que este
ángulo vale 60 menos teta
perfecto entonces en este triángulo se
ha construido un triángulo rectángulo
tengo el ángulo para el ángulo theta la
hipotenusa tiene longitud este a la
altura tiene la longitud 2 y para el
ángulo 60 menos theta la hipotenusa de
nuevo tiene longitud s pero ahora la
altura es de 4 así que voy a copiar
esos dos triángulos acá
este sería el primero que tiene ángulo
el triángulo de aquí es de 60 menos teta
esta longitud de ss de la hipotenusa y
está longitud es cuatro
y por acá tengo el otro triángulo que
tiene ángulo teta hipotenusa s y altura
2 perfecto entonces
cuánto vale el seno de este triángulo de
este ángulo cuánto vale el seno de 60
minutos teta pues por definición de seno
el seno de 60 menos teta va a ser igual
al cateto opuesto entre la hipotenusa es
decir 4 entre s y que hay de el seno de
trata
se note está de acuerdo con este
triángulo valdría 2
valdría 2 / s muy bien ahora si
multiplicó esta ecuación por 2
esto se convierte en un 4
y entonces tengo que el seno de 60 menos
teta es igual a 4 s pero eso también es
igual a dos veces el seno de teta así
que vamos a igualar estas cosas tengo
que el seno
ejemplo escribo así dos veces el seno de
teta va a ser igual a el seno de 60
menos teta
pero nosotros sabemos de nuestros vídeos
de trigonometría podemos aplicar algunas
identidades trigonométricas y podríamos
reescribir esto como dos veces el seno
de teta dos veces el seno de teta va a
ser igual el seno de a menos b es igual
a el seno de a por el coste no debe
menos el seno de b por el coste no de as
es decir en este caso eso se convierte
en el seno de 60
60 por el coche no detecta menos el
coseno de 60
x
por el seno de theta
y bien cuánto vale el seno del 60 pues
nosotros ya sabemos que el seno de 60
vale raíz de 3 sobre 2
de 3 sobre 2 y cuánto vale el coche no
es 60 pues vale un medio así que voy a
reescribir todo esto como dos veces el
seno de teta es igual a
a raíz de tres entre dos por el coche no
detecta menos menos un medio el seno de
teta
ahora bien si sumo un medio seno de teta
de ambos lados tendría cinco medios
cinco medios del seno de teta
es igual a raíz de 3 entre todos por el
coche no de teta y este un medio seno y
tetas se cancela
así que ahora podría multiplicar toda
esta ecuación por 2 y obtener que cinco
veces el seno de teta
es igual a raíz de 3 por el coseno de
teta
ahora bien qué pasa si elevó esta
ecuación al cuadrado lo hago para poder
usar la identidad de que el coche no al
cuadrado detecta más el seno al cuadro
de teta es igual a 1 pues de este lado
tengo 25 seno de teta al cuadrado es
igual a 3 veces no voy a poner coseno al
cuadrado de teta voy a poner uno menos
el seno al cuadrado de teta
pero cuánto va listo pues esto
simplemente es 25 se no cuadra detecta
25 1 cuadra de 30 es igual a 3 menos
tres veces el seno cuadrado de teta
pero eso cuánto vale pues sí y ahora
sumó 13 no sé no cuadra de tetas de
ambos lados obtendría 28
seno cuadrado de teta
es igual a 3 o en otras palabras seno
cuadrado teta es igual a 3 entre 28 o
aún más el seno etc
el seno de teta es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 3 entre 28 y quizás podría
simplificar eso por ejemplo 28 es igual
a 4 por 7 así que podría sacar de aquí
un 2 pero creo que basta con esto
volvamos aquí tenía antes de manipular
esta ecuación que el seno de theta era
igual a 2 entre s
así que
el seno teta es igual a 2 en 3
me lo pongo aquí esto es igual a 2 / s
es lo que obtuvimos de este triángulo y
traca y entonces de allí concluyó que s
s es igual a multiplicó por s y dividido
entre la raíz cuadrada de 3 entre 28 o
lo que es lo mismo multiplicó por su
inverso multiplicativo y obtengo que s
es igual a dos veces la raíz cuadrada de
28 entre 3
bien pues regresando al problema de el
área de este hexágono primero que nada
noten que aquí
ahora que sé cuánto vale s puedo
encontrar esta longitud puede encontrar
esta altura para este triángulo de aquí
y entonces puedo calcular su área vamos
a llamar a esta altura h de height en
inglés que significa altura entonces
bien cuánto vale h pues si un sol
teorema de pitágoras y recuerdo que esta
longitud vale 4 y esto vale 4
simplemente porque es cuánto sube es
estar a la altura del vértice f
entonces yo sé que al cuadrado más 4
cuadrado que es 16 es igual a dice al
cuadrado que es
s valía
2 por la raíz cuadrada 28 en 3 entonces
s al cuadrado es igual a 4 por 28
entre 3
bien entonces si ahora resto 16 de ambos
lados puede escribir que h cuadrada es
igual a 4 por 28
entre 3 voy a poner a 16 con denominador
3 menos 16 por 36 48 48 entre 3 así que
al cuadrado es igual a 4 por 28
48 simplemente es 4 por 12 así que si
factor hizo el 4 me queda el 12
todo eso entre 3d donde h va a ser igual
a la raíz cuadrada de 4 por 28 menos 12
/
o lo que es lo mismo la raíz cuadrada de
4 del 2 la raíz cuadrada de 16 64
entre la raíz de 3 o sea 8 entre la raíz
de 3
esa es la altura de este triangulito así
que cuánto vale el área
déjenme voy a tratar de usar otro color
el área de este triangulito vale 8 entre
la raíz de 3 por la altura que vale 4
perdón esa es la altura la base vale 4
por un medio
así que ocho por cuatro por un medio
entre la raíz de tres o lo que es lo
mismo ocho por dos entre los raíz de
tres así que el área
el área
el área para decir el área de este
triangulito
es igual a 16 entre la raíz de tres pero
noten que tengo cuatro de estos
triangulitos este triangulito de aquí es
idéntico a este triangulito de acá son
congruentes tienen la misma base tienen
la misma altura y lo mismo aplica para
estos triangulitos de aquí
recuerden esta longitud es común los dos
tienen hipotenusa s y base 4 así que
esto de aquí también vale h así que
tengo 4 de estos triangulitos por lo
tanto el área combinada de todos esos
triangulitos toda el área que estoy
sombreando vale 4 veces 4 veces esto así
que tendría que el área de los
triangulitos es 4 por 16 que es 48 entre
raíz de 3 ahora sólo tengo que calcular
el área de este paralelogramo de en
medio de este paralelogramo que voy a
rellenar de naranja
de ese paralelo gramos de ahí bien pues
de este paralelogramo yo conozco la base
la longitud de la base es 8 esta
longitud vale 8 4 y 4 así que sólo tengo
que determinar esta altura tengo que
terminar esta altura de aquí pero bueno
quizás no debería ser h porque ya lo sé
vamos a ponerle a de altura
pero yo sé que aquí tengo un triángulo
rectángulo y más aún esta distancia de
acá es la misma que esta distancia de ti
acá así que
yo tengo que
así lo dicho aquí cometiendo error 4 por
no hay es 48 4 por 16 no es 48 4 por 16
es 64
casi riego todo el problema así que 64
entre raíz de 3
ese es el área que llevamos acumulada
y bien entonces quería calcular
quería calcular esta pero yo sé que a
cuadrada
+ 2 esta longitud de aquí al 2 al
cuadrado o sea 4 es igual a s al
cuadrado pero de nuevo es el cuadrado
simplemente es 4 por 28 entre 3
así que
de aquí obtengo que a cuadrada es igual
a
4 por 28 entre 3
-4 para ponerlo con denominar 3 sería 12
- 12 tercios que sería lo mismo que
cuatro por cuatro tercios por 28
28 - menos 3 perdón y 8 menos 3
es decir la cuadrada es igual a 4 por 25
que sería 100 entre 3 así que
a vale 10 / raíz de 3
ah vale 10 / raíz de 3
esto de aquí
vale 10 entre raíz de 3 de modo que el
área de este paralelogramo es 8 por 10
entre raíz de 3 así que el área
el área de todo este paralelogramo sería
80 realizar otro color eso no se ve
80 / raíz de 3 de modo que si sumo eso
con el área que ya había calculado con
estos 64 entre raíz de tres que ya tenía
obtengo 64 entre raíz de 3 más 80 entre
raíz de 3
esto es lo mismo que 144 / raíz de 3 si
ahora racionalizó el denominador
multiplicando por raíz de 3 / raíz de 3
obtengo 144
144 por raíz de tres entre tres esto
sería el área total
pero 144 entre 3 a cuánto es eso es 48
así que es 48 por raíz de 3 esa sería el
área esto sería igual a m por la raíz de
n
pero el problema nos pide encontrar a m
más n así que
m 48 n van de tres así que esta suma
vale 51